what's going on guys this is rob and the
super bowl trailer for doctor strange
two drops which has all kinds of stuff
in it and uh has a lot more than the
first trailer did and in fact some of
the stuff in the first trailer has
actually been changed and we'll talk
more about that but i feel like i might
have an idea of what's going on here
in doctor strange too that wando really
is the focal point of it all how it is
juan is the bad guy
and what's actually going on but we'll
talk about that once we get to the end
of this whole breakdown right let's
break this trailer down so first things
first one of the things we get here is
dr strange saying that he always has the
same this the same kind of like dream
right and then he wakes up and the
nightmare really begins i mean obviously
it's not meant to be taken as a literal
phrase it's not like i have the same
dream and then when i wake up nightmares
in the corner of my room smiling at me
although that would be creepy but
amazing at the same time
because i really want to see nightmare
uh nightmare looks awesome he looks like
he looks like a garageband guy meets
like a punk rocker like he kind of kind
of bridges the gap between those two
things but the important thing here and
this is actually something that was
spotted by gordon my chief chief
creative officer what he thinks is going
on which i really think is a great idea
that what dr strange is seeing when he
sleeps are his alternate reality
versions dying that's basically what's
happening right when he goes to bed and
he sees like this version of himself
being destroyed or something like that
he's seeing his alternate reality
counterpart destroyed now there is room
for this from marvel comics so those of
you guys who never read spider-verse
you've probably heard of the character
miguel o'hara spider-man 2099 during the
spider-verse event there was an
alternate reality version of himself
that it basically created a headband
that made it possible for him to locate
different versions of spider-man 2099
from around the multiverse and so what
this did is it created a kind of psychic
link between all these various versions
of miguel o'hara from across the
multiverse so that if one was destroyed
then eventually miguel o'hara in the
main marvel universe could both see it
and feel it so there is room for this
for doctor strange to be experiencing
the death of the different versions of
himself from across the multiverse now
following that we get this really really
cool scene where america chavez is
basically being stared down by the
crimson bands of sidorak and she opens a
portal behind herself which seemingly
pulls herself in now this is really
really cool right because right around
that time you get defender strange who
seemingly is either pulled through the
portal or pushed through the portal and
basically looks like he's dead right it
looks like he's just kind of falling
through the portal as like a dead person
maybe he's alive we're not 100 sure but
i would say that this crimson bands of
sidorak right that are basically like
staring down and seemingly screaming at
america chavez that may very well
actually be cedar rack now if it is
meh okay so here's the thing sidorak is
a horse dude this guy is an absolute
monster when it comes to power in marvel
comics and it's really kind of nuts now
some of you guys may have heard of
sidorak some of you all may have not uh
in the scene during infinity war when
doctor strange shot those red bands at
thanos those were the crimson bands of
sidorak right i mean it's one of those
things he's so powerful that doctor
strange and other sorcerer supreme and
even other people who just use magic
actually invoke the power of sidorak and
in fact sidorak is so powerful that
dormammu will invoke the power of
sidorak if he needs to it's really kind
of nuts just how powerful this guy is
one of the other reasons you guys may
have heard of sidorak is because there
was a point in time in marvel comics
when the brother of professor charles
xavier who we'll talk about here in a
second a man named kane marco touched a
stone that he was not supposed to touch
and there was an inscription that was
written on there that said whosoever
touches this gem shall possess the power
of the crimson bands of sidorak
henceforth you who read these words
shall become forevermore a human
juggernaut now does that mean that we
are getting juggernaut in the marvel
cinematic universe i don't know i have
no idea i just thought it was a cool
reference so that's one of the things
like it looks i mean normally whenever
the crimson bands activate it's only
ever because sidorak makes them or
because something else is going on
usually with doctor strange again we'll
talk about that as we circle back around
to the end of this but again focusing on
on defender strange it is cool to see
him he does look cool but it's hard to
tell whether or not he's actually alive
in fact i would go as far as to say that
that looks like a reality that america
chavez happened to be in or was possibly
passing through where doctor strange was
killed in that universe now why it was
he was killed by sidorak or the crimson
band seemingly operating of their own
accord we'll actually talk about here in
a little bit again we'll kind of circle
back around to that but the other cool
thing is about 27 seconds into this
trailer you see doctor strange basically
kind of manifesting the uh at least
seemingly the multiverse or different
worlds all of which are red that looks
like the dark hole now whether or not he
has it in his possession or not we're
not 100 sure but it would make sense
that he would and the reason why is
because we know wanda had the dark hole
at least last time we saw her at the end
of juan division and if he and wanda are
actually working together it would make
sense that stephen strange would be like
i'm going to need that dark hole or like
take it or ask wanda for it and just
like she gives it to him whatever the
case happens to be but it would make
sense that he would have it in his
possession the question you have to ask
is would doctor strange know how to use
it effectively right because one of the
things to know is that steven strange is
the sorcerer supreme but even by his own
admission there's still a lot of stuff
he doesn't know and so when you're
talking about this thing or something
like the dark hold it's possible that he
knows it's dangerous but he doesn't know
exactly what he's getting into by
meddling with it whether or not that's
actually the case not 100 sure doesn't
lend a lot of credence to the idea of
being the sorcerer supreme if you don't
know about something as significant as a
dark hole but regardless uh when you
jump forward a little bit of course you
get the ultron robots now initially the
funny thing about this is when i first
saw them i was kind of hoping they were
doombots obviously they're not they're
ultron robots but as we know from the
different leaks and little things that
have come out it looks like of course
these are being controlled by tony stark
and one of the cool things about this is
this looks like it contains a bit of a
homage to like marvel comics
specifically a couple of different
stories the first one could be like the
trial of magneto and the second one
could be the trial of reed richards now
of course this is obviously doctor
strange being put on trial here but the
important thing is that the the look of
it the feel of it seems reminiscent of
those two things of course the trial of
magneto basically being the story where
magneto handed himself over to the
authorities to atone for his past
misdeeds the trial of reed richards is
where you basically learn the reality of
like galactus uh the significance of
galactus that like he has to exist in
the universe and that people are just
going to have to die because of his
existence just the way it is sorry about
your luck that was literally the trial
of reed richards right like that was
literally the story right like eternity
the living embodiment of the universe
showed up to everybody at the trial of
reed richards the shia the creed the
scroll all those guys gave them cosmic
awareness showed them the grand tapestry
of the universe and was like yeah man uh
galactus has to kill some of y'all in
order to live and he just has to exist
so i mean
i don't know what to tell you right that
was it was one of those really crazy
moments
[Laughter]
from marvel comics now then of course
following that we get the big moment
probably the single biggest moment in
the trailer which is the voice of xavier
it sucks we didn't get to see him if
they're gonna play his voice might as
well show his face it's not like
anybody's just like i wonder who that is
i wonder who that person is whose
slightly bald head we could see from the
side and sounds exactly like professor x
from the fox x-men films
no way it could be him
it's probably just captain america like
no one's thinking that
we all know it's professor x so they
might as well just say it's professor x
right regardless it is cool the other
thing about this though is that if you
look at that stage right you look at
that whole i guess whatever you want to
call the dice however you want to refer
to it there is somebody sitting on the
far left hand side and then of course
you don't really see who's in the middle
but i would say that's probably
professor xavier because there's chairs
everywhere and you have to believe this
professor x he's probably in a
wheelchair right so uh that's probably
professor x in the middle right playing
the whole role of like yoda for the
illuminati basically and then you have
somebody off to the right and then you
have what looks like uh beer and mordo
walking in now in terms of the person
off to the far left i would bet all the
money in my pockets to all the money in
your pockets that's only one of two
people either it's reed richards or it's
tony stark now i would say it's probably
read because when you have that scene
where like doctor strange is being taken
by the ultron robots and basically being
brought to uh to the illuminati group
that they're basically calling the
members together and read is nothing if
not punctual well kind of sometimes it
depends on who's writing the story but i
have to believe that's probably reid
richards right there i also zoomed in
pretty far as grainy as it is and it
looks like it would be read but it's
kind of hard to tell there was nothing
on the body as far as i could tell
regarding like lights or anything like
that any kind of glimmers or anything
that would look like tony stark armor
and if the leaks are true as far as tom
cruise is concerned he looks more like
superior iron man right it looks more
like the indo-sim armor now whether or
not it is actually the endosymtek we
don't really know we won't know until
the movie comes out or until we see him
in one of the trailers of course i don't
really think we will um if tony stark
does exist in doctor strange too they're
going to keep it under wraps like the
whole andrew garfield toby mcguire thing
where like no one's really gonna know
until the movie comes out i mean we're
gonna kind of know right like we're
gonna be like i mean we know but like
we're not gonna definitively know uh but
again you know it's one of those those
little things in terms of the person who
looks like they have longer hair
i'm not really sure who that is my
initial thought is maybe it's some
alternate reality version of thor right
maybe it's like god king thor
who basically took over the odin force
uh in in his universe and then basically
replaced odin right i mean technically
it's called the thor force when thor has
it but like ended up replacing odin uh
we don't fully know right i mean they
look like they have dark hair but again
they're really far away they're really
really small and they're shrouded in
shadow so it's really hard to tell but
regardless like i really do believe
that's reed on the far left side which
fingers crossed is john krasinski
i really hope that's the case now
following that we do get a scene uh
where it basically just looks like
america chavez and doctor strange just
falling through realities some of my
guys thought it was the savage land and
i was like i mean i guess it could be
but like when you look at the scene in
context and like literally they're
falling through portals it just looks
like some alternate reality where maybe
humans never evolved or anything like
that or they're possibly falling through
an alternate reality where the savage
land does exist so those of you guys who
don't know what that is the savage land
was actually a place that was basically
created by the beyonders or created
really by another race i think they were
called the new wally at the request of
the beyonders and basically it's a giant
game preserve so literally like when the
when the savage land was created all
flora and fauna across the world
including like dinosaurs and things like
that were all taken to this place and
then dropped off and they basically live
there it's a really lush jungle
environment right it's literally a slice
out of time and it does have its own
civilization it does have guys that
nobody cares about like hazard right
here nobody cares about him uh but then
you also have a lot of like experiments
that go on there and things along those
lines but it is a cool place right the
savage land is pretty interesting
honestly i would wager that's just a
reality they're passing through we might
only see it for a moment or two if that
at all here's kind of the funny thing
though and here's what's so ironic about
that is that's more reminiscent to the
original infinity gauntlet story than
anything that you saw in infinity war or
avengers in-game right there was a point
in infinity gauntlet when thanos was
fighting drax the destroyer and somebody
else i don't remember who it was maybe
the hulk um and basically used the time
the time gym and threw them through time
to the point where they actually landed
back to the days of the dinosaurs so
that was a really cool thing to see but
it looks like they're just passing
through dimensions right not a whole lot
going on there uh but following that and
this is what's really crazy you get a
scene where it looks like scarlet witch
is fighting captain marvel uh now one of
the other alternatives here and this i
think actually lends a little more
credence is that it's captain universe
the popular theory is that it's captain
marvel and that's the most practical one
to be honest i mean if we're going with
like the nature of the mcu the safe bet
it's probably captain marvel and it's
probably monica rambo's mom right that's
the most likely case i kind of thought
for a minute there it sort of looked
like michael b jordan and i think it'd
be cool if it was right if it was like
johnny storm from like the the fan four
stick movie give that guy his redemption
right because that movie was awful and
michael b jordan was the only good part
of it uh but uh nonetheless you know at
the end of the day it is probably you
know monica rambo's mom maybe like an
alternate version of herself who became
captain marvel instead of carol danvers
which nobody would complain about but
the thing about this is that if it is
captain universe that would be a bigger
deal because someone like captain
universe could legitimately go
toe-to-toe with wanda right with the
scarlet witch assuming she doesn't have
the life force and she's not like house
of m level where she was at her most
powerful and like altering the
multiverse with somebody like captain
marvel
not necessarily so but as we know the
marvel cinematic universe plays by a
different set of rules than marvel
comics does and kevin feige and all them
have said like the power of captain
marvel is the most powerful force in the
marvel cinematic universe and so it kind
of makes sense that somebody like that
would be able to go against wanda
assuming wand is not using like the full
totality of her power it is a cool thing
one of the other things that i thought
would have been kind of cool because one
of the big questions people have is like
what role is wanda playing in all this
and this idea that wanda could basically
come along and people are looking for a
for a way to like introduce mutants
right that one could say like you know
we need mutants or something along those
lines that would seem forced i don't
really know how you make that work but
it would be interesting to have a kind
of house of ms event where the movie
ends and wanda is like no more
multiverse and basically wipes the
multiverse out and in doing so basically
those individuals who were able to
escape basically do again there's room
for that in marvel comics right i mean
like in marvel they did that they've
done that multiple on multiple occasions
right like during the original house of
an event you had the white hot room
where you had like rachel summers and i
think psylocke and then jamie braddock
were all basically hanging out there
it's a place outside of space and time
uh during the age of apocalypse event in
the 1990s when that universe was
destroyed a handful of people like dark
beast holocaust so on they basically
jumped through the imran crystal to
escape the collapse of that reality nate
gray x-men did as well just this
ridiculously powerful guy but you've
seen that kind of thing happen before
people escaping collapsed realities
hyperion did it right during hickman's
avengers new avengers well technically
he was left in the the empty space that
was two universes when they collided
during the incursions like literally
hyperion survived the destruction of two
universes that gives you an indication
of how powerful that is like the guy was
ridiculously overpowered uh but again
there's room here for them to do that
kind of thing the problem with this is
if wanda were to like reconcile
basically wipe out the multiverse and
they were to use that as a means to
consolidate down the fox verse right
it's like the fantastic four the x-men
deadpool you know and they were to use
that to basically bring together or to
consolidate uh the sony versus like
andrew garfield and like toby mcguire or
something like that
how do you explain the purpose of king
the conqueror right i mean how do you
how do you make sense of that right so
can they keep that kang train going if
there is no multiverse right that's
that's one of the big things because
literally the recreation of the
multiverse is why king even exists in
the first place but regardless following
that and this is one of the cool things
schumer gorath so schumacher or
gargantos if you want to be a dick about
it uh he's basically got a change in
this trailer in the first trailer you
saw him but in this one you see the
exact same thing but it looks like he's
covered in chaos magic and if that's the
case then perhaps shumogorath is not
operating of his own faculties that
somebody else is now this goes into the
next thing which is basically two
scarlet witch's meaning that you've got
wanda with a scar on her head and then
you've got like the scarlet witch this
looks like wanda meeting a variant of
herself the other thing about this is
that when you get further into the
trailer really towards the end you
basically end up seeing this kind of
zoom in shot where you zoom in on
wanda's eye and despite the fact that
she's outside the inside of her eye
looks like a room and it looks like
there's somebody in it off to the side
it's kind of hard to tell right it's
this is a little little murky there
right i mean you know youtube
compression and all that kind of stuff
uh and one thing i do want to mention we
do get like zombie doctor strange looks
amazing he kind of looks like null the
symbiote god right like the really cool
scene from like the tv spot where he's
like walking up all janky on you know to
the top of the mountain and everything
that's cool right but like zombie doctor
strange looks amazing but here's the
thing and here's what i think is
actually going on here so in that scene
when when you see the illuminati or you
only hear the voice of a professor x he
says we should tell him the truth right
tell him what's actually going on i
think what's happening here
is that the belief is that because of
doctor strange's actions during the
events of like spider-man no way home
perhaps a few other things he did
between the end of that movie and the
start of this one that he was the one
who broke the multiverse i think it was
actually wanda who did it and i think
it's been going on for quite some time
not only do i think it's wanda who did
it in like west view and all that kind
of stuff i think it's wandas who are
doing it that basically what's happening
here the reason why schuma gorath looks
different uh is because cathone had
basically found some way to break free
catholic exists catholic seized control
of wanda and the reason why this matters
why you see like two wandas why you see
like america chavez passing through like
dead realities is because essentially
is conquering universes and wanda is
always the way that he's let in it's
kind of a throwback to like the idea of
the molecule man right so those you guys
don't know what that means the molecule
man is a ridiculously powerful guy right
he's a guy who can basically control the
atomic structure of matter the name
molecule man's misnomer but he can
control basically matter on a
multiversal level right the guy's just
ridiculously op but what you learned
really years after his introduction is
that the molecule man was essentially an
experiment by the beyonders that his
origin is the same in every single
universe that his life is the exact same
in every single universe and that the
intention was for the beyonders to
basically create the molecule man in
every universe and to give him all that
power in every single universe so that
when the time came they could basically
destroy all the molecule men at the same
time and when those molecule men
exploded they would take their universe
with it now i'm not saying that we're
getting like this carbon copy of that in
this movie but what i am saying is in
every single universe across the
multiverse wanda's origin is basically
the same right in some form or fashion
she basically ends up being captured by
like some evil force out there right
some some you know either whether it's
like hydra or whatever she's basically
given powers and then essentially loses
everything and then basically goes
insane and the results of that is in
every single one of these universes
cathode uses that moment of weakness to
seize control and in turn wanda is
basically the way in which he enters a
universe and then wipes it out now maybe
something like uh like like schumacher
how you explain that i'm not entirely
sure you know the marvel cinematic
universe because it operates by a
different set of rules it could very
well be that shumogorath was created by
kethung or shumagorath is yet another
person who was was basically taken by
cathode and then controlled by him the
reason why i say cathone here more than
anything else is because if you look at
shumo gorath it looks like he's got
chaos magic runes all over him wanda we
know uses chaos magic the source of
chaos magic seemingly is catholic right
catholic the creator of the dark hold
like all the stuff roots back to him and
what better way to introduce him is just
this overarching villain than to
basically say he's the one controlling
wanda that when you have that zoom in
shot on wanda's eye she's the one stuck
in that room she's being controlled
right she basically is being being like
moved out of the way we know that
happened from the events of like secret
empire right in marvel comics that when
catholic took control of wanda there was
nothing she could do she was literally
pushed into the back of her own mind and
basically kept us something akin to a
cage right i mean they don't really show
it per se they more like say it but like
that's the thing it's like that's
entirely possible and maybe that's the
truth that professor xavier is talking
about in saying that like wanda is the
most dangerous person in the entirety of
the multiverse because in every single
universe where cathode takes hold wanda
is the reason why wanda is the basically
the portal or the kind of opening he
uses to seize control of a person and
then in those different universes using
wanda he destroys doctor strange he
destroys anybody who could be like a
credible threat to him right so like all
the superheroes on those worlds and then
conquers them and like subjugates them
right now why he's doing that i don't
know i mean in the comics catholic was
just a dick right so he was just doing
those things because he was a bad guy
and that's what bad guys do but the
other part of this is that in marvel
comics you have the dark dimension right
the dimension of dormammu in the marvel
cinematic universe you have the exact
same thing but we know that the dark
dimension is basically a combination of
seemingly different dimensions and
possibly even other universes that have
all been seized by dormammu right
controlled by him that he's always
looking to expand his power but
basically his universe just kind of
grows outward right as he conquers a
universe now his universe is twice the
size when he conquers the third universe
his universe is three times the size and
they're all places that are subjugated
by him this is kind of a backwards
version of the splinter realms that
we've seen in marvel comics those who
don't know what that is there was a
point in marvel where basically the dark
dimension was just a singular location
by just a singular place but in the old
magic comics which i think came out in
the 1990s a story that focused on ileana
rasputin you ended up learning that
there was some kind of conflict
somewhere along the line and this
basically led to the dark dimension
being shattered being splintered and so
when dormammu and umar came from the
realm of the falten into the dark
dimension they conquered that giant
plane of existence and then everything
else was ruled by the hell lords and so
the thing about this is that if the
multiverse has returned and now you have
universes crossing over everything's
been thrown into disarray that it's
entirely possible that dormammu lost
control of his dark dimension and in
doing so now beings like catholic and
those guys are essentially free so maybe
we're seeing the results of some kind of
demonic war i don't know i mean that's
pretty far-fetched even for this movie
but i think it'd be kind of cool right
something going on like something bigger
happening behind the scenes than just
like catholics he's in control of wanda
and just wiping out whole universes or
like conquering different universes
whatever the case is but regardless let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section right this trailer was
amazing i absolutely loved it right it
just had some some great moments again
like zombie doctor strange like when
he's got like all those arms behind him
and all that kind of stuff he looks like
no and it kind of gives you like these
sinners market vibes right like in
hickman's avengers and new avengers when
dr strange sold his soul or tried to
sell a soul for 100 percent of uh of
absolute power and couldn't do it
because he didn't have a complete soul
his soul was tainted because of like the
black magic he'd used over the course of
his existence uh it's cool right it's a
really interesting concept but
regardless yeah zombie doctor strange
looks legit i'm curious what role he's
gonna play as it stands now i count four
doctor stranges in this trailer so let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace